et on va plus loin avec marie roger
biloa directrice d'africains
internationale avec nous en direct de
yaoundé au cameroun dont jean-marie
roger
et voilà marié roger qui s'installe vous
nous entendez
ravi d'être avec vous où que vous soyez
plutôt avec nous ce mardi face à vous
bruno daroux de la rédaction de france
24 bonjour brunoh bonjour rationnel il
leur fallait 65 sièges il en obtient de
60 de leurs hezbollah et ses alliés
perdent leur majorité au liban résultats
des législatives qui avaient lieu
dimanche
première victime avec le parti chiite le
courant patriotique libre du président
michel aoun doublé dans le camp chrétien
par le parti des forces libanaises de
son éternel rival samir geagea et
l'arrivée de 13 nouveaux élus issus de
la contestation du système écouter l'un
d'entre eux
c'est un jour de fête nationale après
deux ans et demi à voir crier notre
colère contre ce gouvernement de
l'injustice ouvrons une nouvelle ère
pour le changement au liban c'est un
jour de fête
bruno daroux conclusions de ces
législatives le début de la fin du
système confessionnel conspué dans la
rue 1 depuis des mois ou bien le
rapprochement de l'arabie saoudite et
donc l'éloignement de l'iran à écouter
c'est un peu compliqué à dire parce que
en fait il y as we une baisse assez
nette du bloc chiite on va dire le
hezbollah et ses alliés qui n'ont pas
fait un bon score lors de ces élections
il y a aussi un petit regain du côté des
forces libanaises donc du côté du camp
chrétien opposés aux blocs chiites il y
a évidemment c'est très notable
l'émergence de ces treize députés issus
en fait de la contestation très sévère
qui a secoué le liban depuis deux ans
maintenant mais il y à aussi 40% de
participation seulement ce qui veut dire
que 60% des libanais se sont abstenus
sur doute un peu dégoûté par par le
système politique qu'ils connaissent
donc en fait on est un peu dans un entre
deux si vous voulez c'est à dire que il
à début de changement c'est peut-être la
fin de l'hégémonie du bloc chiite mais
en face il n'y a pas de camps qui est
suffisamment de deux voix 2 sièges pour
former une majorité ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait ça n'arrange pas
paradoxalement alors qu'eux mêmes et il
ya des signaux 1 2 un peu de ce nouveau
liban qui émerge à travers ses treize
députés ça vient compliquer le
fonctionnement de ce système qui malgré
tout reste en place sauf que à la
différence des élections de 2018 on ne
sait pas de quel côté ça va pencher va y
avoir des tractations ça va être
compliqué et donc les prochaines
semaines des prochains mois en plus y'a
l'élection du président qui est prévue à
l'automne prochain on ne sait pas trop
sur quoi tout ça va déboucher
paradoxalement il est donc toujours pas
de stabilité peut être à venir au liban
marc ayrault jean on commence néanmoins
à voir enfin dans le paysage politique
les effets de l'exaspération qu'ont
exprimé les libanais dans la rue
je trouve pas on voit pas c'est parce
qu'il faut quand même s'arrêter un peu
le poil abstentions c'est clair que 60 %
de gens l'avaient pas voter dans un pays
dont on nous dit que la société la
situation socio-économique et du nitrate
depuis deux mois 2018 que la livre
libanaise a perdu 95% savane que le prix
des produits de première nécessité a été
multiplié par 10 de 80% de la population
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté alexia à
dos les hôpitaux rade ne peuvent pas
fonctionner et correctement il ya un
exode énorme des forces vives et une
économie extravertie puisque 90% des
biens de consommation sont importés en
dollars et donc quand on a la chance
d'aller voter pour changer une chose
quand même je ne sais pas sur quoi on
compte d'autres
bien sûr la politique à ces limitations
elle n'est ce pas on a bien vu que dans
celui là il ya un an au liban à ce
système le confessionnalisme
contrepartie des blocs qui suivent
l'idée des religions de certaines de
certains critères j'allais dire
communautaire et est vraiment en place
de manière dure est forte et que s'il ya
une chose sur laquelle la classe
politique est d'accord c'est de ne pas
changer et donc des changements
justement transformer la société ça
vient par le poids de nouvelles forces
et on l'a vu donc depuis 10 mois de 2009
le mouvement de contestation énorme et
qui s'est amplifié après l'explosion de
mon corps de beyrouth ans qu'on se
disait les prochaines élections ça va
être une transformation donc c'est
dommage qu'il y ait cette lassitude que
les libanais disons peut rien faire les
politiques et ben c'est pas tout à fait
vrai parce que le fait que ce soit un
petit peu mobilisés à l'esha pendu au
fait que le hezbollah ne peut la
majorité il faut pas être dans
l'illusion que de la perte de poids de 2
du hezbollah parce que très probablement
et vont continuer à
diriger l'assemblée nationale contre
continuent à peser ya que là ils ont
perdu là même la majorité de très peu
film est plutôt serré sont les accords
de taef à la de toute manière add-on
voilà au parlement la présidence
actuellement occupée par nabih berry du
parti amal qui fait partie du bloc
chiite et qui continuera
vraisemblablement
exercer un
métier à son 6e mandat qui continue et
qui continuera d'exercer si j'arrive à
former une majorité comme ah bah oui
parce que c'est ça la grande inconnue
mais je sais d'accord et faisait mari
roger serre que dans un pays qui a connu
une telle crise le fait qu'ils aient la
présidence du parlement on revient
revient en chine revient à shit mais
après s'il ya pas de majorité derrière
qui soutient le président chiite ça va
quand même être un problème et oui
effectivement je suis d'accord avec
marie roger que le fait qu'ils aient cas
de 60% des libanais dans cette situation
qu'ils ne se soient pas déplacés aux
urnes oui quand on voit quand même que
ceux qui se sont déplacés aux urnes ont
permis déjà de faire bouger un peu les
choses mais selon la raddho qs et je
sais que c'est insuffisant oui le 13
députés issus de la constestation sur
128 malheureusement ça veut pas j'ai
complètement le fonctionnement de ce
site le bloc chiite qui perd sa majorité
ce sont les alliés du hezbollah non pas
le hezbollah lui-même à qui ressortent
affaiblis néanmoins on peut dire que les
lire en paix d'une certaine mère son
activisme régional bruno et que je sais
pas si c'est vraiment l'iran pour le
coup qui paie son activisme régionales
parce que en fait l'iran a toujours usé
de son influence sur le hesbollah là je
crois que ces élections marquent quand
même le leu leu la suite en fait de ce
mouvement social qu'effectivement on a
observé depuis l'automne 2010 9 qui se
traduit un peu dans les urnes au
détriment du bloc chiite en particulier
dans certaines localités dans le dans le
sud du pays ce assez c'est quand même
assez important donc ça envoie un
message au hezbollah et donc par
ricochet forcément à l'iran mais de là à
dire comme c'est insuffisant encore une
fois de là à dire que ça va changer
fondamentalement la politique de téhéran
vis-à-vis du liban personnellement je le
pense pas des aveux aussi du courant
patriotique libre du président michel
aoun dont on sait dire que le gendre
gebrane bassil été particulièrement
contesté dans la rue c'est un un soutien
peut-être plus grand en tout cas au sein
du un rééquilibrage des forces au sein
du duo du du courant du bloc chrétien en
faveur des
de samir geagea raid et 2,2 et de son
parti cela indique d'après vous marie
roger biloa là aussi que l'arabie
saoudite qu'on avait dit
considérablement affaibli à la fois on
s'en souvient par les allers retours de
saad hariri et puis ensuite la faire à
chaud dgi et d'une certaine manière
remise en selle dans la région
elle à l'arrivée soft euros là vous
savez quand on parle des expatriés qui
balaie dire c'est une par une situation
particulière où on estime qu'il ya
autant de l'ibère de l'ubs à l'est à
l'intérieur du pays qu'à l'extérieur et
que y contribue quand même pour un tiers
du pib qui est ensuite libre et beaucoup
sont dans les émirats et notamment à
l'arabie saoudite et on a vu que
parce qu'un député a osé que
critiquer
la politique
sans dialogue il aimait la guerre
inhumaine en fait la baisse on dit a
menacé de bloquer les transferts
d'argent qui font vivre dubois partie la
situation je la sens du pardon de la
mutation ils sont bien là mais je crois
que
aujourd'hui leur visibilité et n'est pas
au premier plan ce qui frappe toujours
c'est ce système politique
libanais que les libanais eux mêmes il
le disait encore aujourd'hui quand
d'écouter les commentaires et dans un
état de mort clinique et conteste
constaté mais pas déclaré officiellement
se dire ça très longtemps qu'on veut le
réformer et on empêche mains de ces
élections voilà on a pas parce qu'il y
avait eu un cheminement est allé us
mollahs qui a perdu sa majorité mais on
aura tout vu les mêmes blocages
et on a toujours ce souci avec le fmi
c'est à dire le financement est un
besoin de financement la main et comme
partout mais là-bas très de manière très
cruciale
le fmi a promis 3 milliards
de dollars une somme qui considéré comme
dérisoire vu les besoins mais qu'ils
n'auront pas techniquement certains ce
que celle il expliqué cet agent ne peut
pas être décaissés en 2023 parce qu'il
ya pas mal de conditions arrive là à
réunir qui ne pourront l'être que
lorsqu'il y aura un nouveau président
c'est à dire en octobre on verra fin de
l'année et pendant ce temps de la
monnaie continue de s'effondrer les
réserves ont fondu comme neige au soleil
et voilà c'est pas le la à bissau dit si
elle intervient ce sera sans doute d'un
corpo financer d'une manière avait
évidemment comme on dit ce triste h avec
des conditions
merci marie roger autre sujet à un coup
d'état quelques coups d'état la france
nie avoir un quelconque lien ni
information d'ailleurs au sujet du
prétendu putsch écarté la semaine
dernière au mali la junte au pouvoir à
bamako affirme en effet avoir déjoué un
coup de force soutenue depuis l'étranger
par une puissance occidentale sans
préciser toutefois laquelle un haut
gradé le colonel amadou keita d ont été
mis aux arrêts que sait-on de lui un
bruno daroux kaki et ils ont ces
quelques petites choses sur lui enfin
des jalles annonce de cette tentative de
putsch qu'il y aurait donc eu lieu il y
a déjà quelques jours par la junte
malienne ça n'a pas été corroborée un de
sources extérieures donc pour le monde
et on est obligé un peu de croire la
jeune malienne sur parole qui dit
qu'elle a déjoué une tentative de putsch
il ya quelques jours visiblement d'après
ce qu'elle dit une tentative de putsch
jour qui a été orchestrée siro provient
de l'intérieur par une partie de ceux
qui sont actuellement au pouvoir et
notamment le colonel amadou keita alors
qu'il fait partie du cnt le conseil
national de transition qui regroupe 120
membres qui fait un peu office de
parlement entre guillemets en attendant
que les autorités militaires remettent
le pouvoir aux autorités civiles dans un
horizon
assez loin car il était considéré comme
étant proche de l'homme fort du cnt il
n'était pas très connu en tout cas
c'était un colonel qui faisait partie
des des putschistes de la première heure
dès 2020 et voilà qu'il est arrêté dans
des circonstances qui pour l'instant au
moment où on se parle reste quand même
un peu ténébreuse ce putschiste de la
première heure en 2020 il pourrait être
lié à la franche marie roger biloa
s'est-elle d'après vous qui est accusé
par le mali au sujet de ce coup d'état
et de cette fameuse puissances
occidentales
eh bien on est dans l'escaladé de la
surenchère et elle a des partisans à
travers l'afrique
tout je crois bien au sens us contre la
france dans la société malienne et
ce désamour de la france manifeste aussi
ailleurs à travers le continent et c'est
ce qui fait qu'on a pu lire la plus
entendre certains comparer à 6 me
coûtera 2 bout à l'autre de
gaulle au moment où il est sorti du
commandant du commandement intégré de
l'otan
68-66 pardon
qu'il a dénoncé unilatéralement toute
une série d'accords avec les américains
johnson l'avait refusé l homme mais de
pardon et de gaulle était passé outre on
a vu aussi certains fermé que les
irrégularités dans la façon de mettre
fin à la mission barkan ou de jeu 5
sahel ou de couper les liens avec parra
de partenaires occidentaux sa sortie
n'était qu'un mâle résiduelles dans une
action historique de libération coûte à
l'ancienne puissance coloniale donc
voyez qu'un discours là qui se met en
place et qui fait que les gens tiennent
énorme problème de légitimité s'est joué
sur deux choses d'abord le patriotisme
n'est ce pas et aussi ce sentiment anti
français mais on remarque en ce moment
c'est que ya des signes des signes de
lassitude
opère au sein de la population quand on
l'a vu aussi avec lorsqu'on active
sentiment là cela
très classe était pas tribale mais comme
en côte d'ivoire en parler d' ivoirité
salut ça fait florès un temps au bout du
compte ça ne peut pas régler les
problèmes des gens et c'est un peu ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui lé maillon
beaucoup de
la situation économique est dramatique
les libertés sont gratuits
la classe politique maintenant commence
à se rebeller même ceux qui étaient les
partenaires de la junte au sein de cette
coalition je pense à par exemple cheikh
oumar sissoko qui était qui est ce
fameux réalisateur de signer une grande
figure de la politique malienne selon
lui puisqu'il était le coordinateur d'un
mouvement de la société civile qui était
associé à la tente qui pressent encore
associé à la pension est pas de renégats
qui prive healy qui privilégie un moment
de leurs intérêts personnels aux
intérêts du peuple malienne comme le dit
ti et demandent le départ de magath donc
il ya des distensions
maintenant et c'est toujours la france
est partie il ya eu des problèmes des
attaques terroristes au à la frontière
du togo tout de suite oui un membre
d'une période de transition est monté au
créneau pour à dire que c'est la france
qui est un essai oui je crois que ça
commence à la brune audard ou avec en
plus cette sortie informel désormais du
g5 sahel par le par le mali le mali joue
la politique du pire la france ne pourra
plus rester encore longtemps comme
l'arbre qui cache la forêt le le bouc
émissaire d'une certaine manière des
difficultés de cette jungle parce qu'en
fait en fait toute la question c'est de
savoir si ce sentiment anti français il
est absolument majoritaire ou est-ce
qu'il est instrumentalisé
notamment par des pouvoirs qui ne sont
quand même pas totalement légitime
puisque ce sont des mêmes déboires
putschiste nommé l'issue de coup d'état
je vous rappeler que ce seront eux mêmes
des gens qui sont au pouvoir après un
putsch dont ce qui pose déjà
un problème il ya sans doute évidemment
dans la population malienne eu une
partie qui est d'accord avec ce
sentiment anti français après l'action
de l'instrumentalisation de ce sentiment
notamment par les jeunes c'est quand
même une grande question à ce qui est
clair c'est que la jeune pour se
légitimer joue à fond la carte anti
françaises et plus généralement
anti-occidentale donc en mettant fin
effectivement à la à la mission mark and
en se désengageant du g5 sahel en s'en
remettant aussi à des puissances
extérieures comme la russie le fameux
groupe wagner est ce que cette stratégie
à moyen et long terme et nabeul c'est
franchement toute la question dans un
pays qui a aussi besoin de l'aide
économique européenne et internationale
pour essayer de de subsister à ses
propres besoins merci bruno daroux
mercier également avoue marie roger
biloa vous étiez avec tous en direct de
yahoo mais on vous retrouve lundi
prochain dont on va plus loin et nous eh
bien on se retrouve dans quatre minutes
pour un nouveau genre